okay I was playing a lot of bullet-like
off stream so we'll have one game on
stream this is rated have to protect my
rating I once won both or I won once
before let's play e5 let's play this
move order ooh
okay White's already lost the beauty of
the Stafford gambit so beautiful look at
this if you're just joining you're
joining right on time
oh I hung a bishop though oh no I got
overconfident oh uh I have to settle for
a draw maybe I don't want to draw but I
have to draw No
can i play on for a wind there's this
move how bad is this move it's a move
I'm taking unnecessary risk this is
really bad oh this is really bad oh I
can take the rook okay then quite miss
sat now I'm threatening mate
the risk is maybe to hang off what a
game to start the stream okay it's still
complicated Queen c5 Keaney eight and
maybe I'm alive I think I'm alive ooh
that's a move g6 or yeah g6 like a g6
could play this move play Queen Queen
here
no it's so weird I'm pinning the bishop
I'm everything's on the back rank
especially my pieces and I can take this
still threatening discoveries yeah to do
this move and then this move
again I don't know what's going on but I
think it's okay
oh don't hurt me the Bishop's pinned
know what's meat oh it's so such a
beautiful mate but so ugly - I can't
even eat five was me know all the
terrible finish I should just end the
stream